what does that mean ultra processed
there's like a spectrum of processing
that a food can undergo so if you look
at like a piece of steak that's meat
that has been processed right you've
cooked it you've basically outsourced
some degree of digestion to make the
steak more palatable easier to break
down same goes for vegetables when we
cook vegetables we're processing when
we're when we're cutting things you know
with a knife and fork we're processing
them to some degree ultra processing is
when for example you take grain flour
and you just you know put it through
these myriad processes that make it so
easily digestible that becomes so
rapidly
broken down and absorbed at the top of
your small intestine ultra processing
also occurs to fats so like grain and
seed oils like canola oil corn oil
soybean oil we know that one step in the
production process deodorization
actually creates a small but significant
amount of trans fats in those oils it
takes very little effort for your body
to assimilate they don't require jaw
vigor to chew and break down our bodies
begin to assimilate them almost
immediately that flood of sugar